aha you've done very well this evening
can you tell us what you've won I won
the junior sportswoman of the year and
for what achievements did you achieve in
2010 11 well I got the divisional
champion and the British records I've
got the British champ British junior
champion and best junior lifter and all
the world records in powerlifting and
then I did the european championships
and again i broke on my world records
and they've got best junior lifter and i
play second in my way cousin great wow
just a few achievements can you tell us
a little bit about what you've recently
achieved I think it was last weekend
yeah just come back on Sunday from
Glasgow and I competed in the WD fpf
world powerlifting championships it was
really good weekend I managed to break
all my world record European records and
British records again I placed first in
the junior in t1 category and then I
play second behind the world champion
mary anderson and so to really happy
that i didn't expect to you I shocked I
think I surprised myself what an amazing
achievement and and how do you feel
about being here tonight and once all
the other talented athletes and
obviously winning your reward it's
really good i mean i know a lot of
people who were here to this evening and
so what talks about their recent
achievements and talk just talk to other
like sports men and women it's been
really good and really inspiring to hear
what they do not let alone be recognized
in my sport but recognize other people's
talents and i think it's a really
important part of the sporting industry
is that you not only recognize yourself
that you recognize others along
which will give you like you know a team
like a teen spirit because you're
together you compete for the same
country